- There's this really pivotal scene
in the Thanksgiving episode
of the show "Masters of None".
Angela Bassett plays a mom.
She's a mother to Denise.
She turns to her, she says,
"Honey, we're minorities
"and we have to work twice
as hard to get half as far."
(slow acoustic guitar music)
For me, Imposter Syndrome,
there was never one big moment.
It was all kind of like smaller moments.
One of the first ones I felt was
I went to a very diverse high school.
There was like Latinos, black people,
Asian people, Indian
people, and I ended up going
to college in Providence, Rhode Island,
and I went to this liberal arts college.
I was there on a scholarship,
and I remember my first day on campus.
It was a sea of white people,
and I was so surprised, and
I just thought the world
was like my high school.
I never felt such a lack of diversity.
It was really shocking to
me, and I felt insecure.
I think I worked hard because
I wanted to convince myself
that I belonged there.
- To me, Imposter Syndrome is
a person who never takes in
their successes and always
feels like they're waiting
on the next shoe to drop,
or waiting on somebody
to find them out.
When I started my company Mae B,
which is a stationary
company for women of color,
I remember hitting these
really big milestones,
and one of them was I was
featured in Essence Magazine
six months into starting my business,
and I could never take that in.
I could never say, you know what?
This happened because I was bold enough
to reach out to the magazine.
This happened because I started
this company from scratch.
It was never about what I did.
It was about, well maybe
it was just the universe,
but it wasn't about my
hard work, dedication
to making that happen.
- My first paid internship
was a non-profit in D.C.,
and it was for an internship
program for my college,
and other colleges in
California and also had
a couple of Ivy League
schools involved with it.
I was one of maybe five students
that had a paid internship,
and there were about 200
students in the program.
I kept telling myself
that I didn't deserve
to have a paid internship.
The Ivy kids didn't
have a paid internship.
It didn't make sense to me
despite having worked before
and being a politics major and
being in D.C. where politics
is such a big thing, I just
told myself that it was luck.
Kids who I felt were more
qualified or deserved it
more than I did, didn't have
the same experience that I had.
- Once I started becoming a
manager and leading teams,
and being the head of
departments and things like that,
more often than not, not
only am I the only woman,
but I'm the only person of color.
- When you're a black woman,
you don't get to be mediocre.
You don't get to walk
into a place and say,
you know what, hmm, I'm just
gonna be all right today.
- I think black women are taught
that we are not deserving, as
much as I hate to say that,
and I think that it stuck
with me unfortunately.
I work hard and consciously I feel
that I am deserving of things,
but subconsciously I don't feel that way.
I attribute everything to luck
as opposed to just attributing it to me.
- I think Imposters
Syndrome is something that
as women of color, we're
always going to come across,
and it's really how do you handle it?
Feeling alone, feeling like a fraud,
feeling like wait, how did I get here?
Do I deserve to be here?
- And there's pressure as a black women
to always be strong,
to always be fearless,
to always have this hardened exterior
because if we show any part of ourselves
that is actually human,
then that makes us weak,
or that makes us less valuable.
- I have to keep telling
myself that everyone
does not necessarily know more than me,
or deserved to be here any more than I do.
- These are things that
I have to remind myself
every single day because if I don't,
I'll fall back into this
place where it's like
okay, what happens when
somebody doesn't think
I'm good enough or am
I actually good enough?
- And there's that old saying,
"fake it 'til you make it",
and I just kind of try to do that
until I realized I'm
not faking it anymore.
I'm just like, I'm just slaying it.
(slow, relaxing electronic music)
(creaking sign)